oh
you can see the air oh that's cool this
is the air of
nike air hi my name is nicole mclaughlin
and i'm a designer who up cycles things
so i take
old things and make them new and so
today i'm going to be taking discarded
shoes and turning them into a vest
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'd say upcycling is kind of just
working with what you have
it's a resourceful type of design where
there's already pre-existing things and
just using that as a base to create
something out of
i was creating these things and i didn't
know that there was
a term for it and then it started being
coined like
on the internet that i'm an upcycling
designer i'd say my approach
is to really keep and consider
that child sense of wonder the way that
i would think
as a child and have like such a strong
imagination for things
i really try to apply that to my work
and i always just allow myself the
freedom to explore an
idea so today i'm going to be taking
discarded shoes
and turning them into a vest by taking
them apart and i'm going to lay them out
flat just to get a feel for
what the shoes are and what materials i
want to use and then
start sewing them by hand
so the first thing i'm going to do is
just lay down this vest
i'll be using a carhartt jacket i
actually removed the sleeves and made
that the best base
i want to see kind of what i'm working
with in terms of material
shape anything i want to avoid like this
pocket here
only because if i'm hand sewing if i sew
directly into it it's going to be really
difficult to sew i really love
this uh sherpa lining so we'll see how
that kind of
meshes with all of the shoe parts that
i'm about to take apart and include in
this
so i have a bunch of shoes that are like
half pairs random just kind of
used and destroyed pairs of shoes which
i think
color wise it's going to be really
bright and awesome
i get materials in a couple of different
ways
thrift stores just around the area if
they lose pairs of shoes like if they
only have half pairs of shoes they'll
be like to do with them so it's been
really cool to find another use for them
so i'm just going to take the laces off
because once you remove the laces you
can kind of see how like
the tongue is able to move a little bit
more and
you start to get a better feel for like
what you can use on the shoe
[Music]
it is really like a puzzle and just kind
of figuring out
what what works and moving it around and
kind of messing with it
until it looks right there really is no
proper
way to start doing this or going about
it but you just have to
go with what the material is doing i try
not to alter it that much
i'm not completely deconstructing it and
reconstructing it to the point where
it's like not recognizable of what it
was
before you know it's a part of issue you
know what that piece
was on a shoe and now it's on a garment
and you can really see that
like that's that's beautiful i love that
after college i was really really lucky
to get
an internship at reebok in boston so i
was doing graphic design
for four years they're doing classics
graphics i was doing like retro
archive t-shirts and allen iverson
jerseys and
throwback things i feel like i was able
to understand
clothing and shoes a lot better because
that wasn't my background that isn't
anything i studied but just being
surrounded by it you get curious
and then being surrounded by piles and
piles of shoes that were getting
discarded
naturally made me very curious as well
it was really the perfect like breeding
ground for what i do now because it was
like
there's just constant material for you
to work with
all right i think i have what we need to
start this
i'm gonna grab exacto knives
i'm gonna get a fresh blade on here
and then this is the therapeutic part
for me
where it's just taking apart the uppers
off of the shoes
and being careful not to slice your
finger off
and then once the upper is off of it i
obviously have a perfectly intact sole
that i'm able to use for other projects
which i do make a lot of
shoes and that's one of my most
frequently asked questions
is where do i get the soles for my shoes
uh
and so i always just say every pair of
shoes has
a sole on it and so do with that as you
will
and i've been taking apart shoes for
like
years now but it took me a while to be
able to do it like this only because
there's different ways that you can
detach a shoe there's different
types of like glues and acetones and
that kind of stuff that helps you remove
it
i personally like to keep all of that i
just think it
brings more character into the shoe but
then also sometimes i'll go in
and you'll see these stitch lines here
which is called a strobel
and so sometimes if you if the shoe's
not lifting up that easily you can
go in and cut those and it will help
lift it up
the heel counter is always the hardest
part and you'll see me probably
struggling to get it off on some of
these shoes because it has the most
stability within the shoe but then we
also might
benefit from using a scissor on it as
well
and i don't cut the whole thing with
scissors because you don't get as clean
of a line so
but it's good for those small little
pieces at the end one of my favorite
parts
about this is seeing a 3d shape like
this go
flat and how the details that make up
the shoe that gives it that accentuated
3d feel
put flat on a vest is just i don't know
something about it is really
unique ooh and the back side too is
really cool
i've been known to to use the wrong side
of the shoe just because i like the way
that the back looks better
you gain more of this like tight mesh
material whereas outside is very cleaned
and finished i kind of like the
roughness of that side
but i think i'd prefer to maybe have
that color pop but we'll see what it
looks like once i have all the pieces
sometimes people approach sustainability
with a very rigid mindset of
this is what it has to be we have a
target we have to check that box instead
of just allowing
the creative freedom to make something
there's so much that needs to be done
that
isn't being done right now and just some
really clear and simple
solutions when it comes to circularity
i mean that's a huge word that is used
around upcycling because
it is just taking things that we've had
for years and years and
prolonging the life of it i i don't see
myself designing any other way i think
now that i'm in the world of
sustainability i don't see myself going
anywhere
it's kind of sad because these ones
weren't really that worn
but there was no friend for it so
now it'll be possibly a pocket or
something
that's another thing with like shoe
uppers you could do maybe like some type
of
pocket which i love to include in my
projects functionality is
probably one of the most important
things to my creation process
kind of the through line of my design i
love pockets i love being able to store
things i love
packing things and the idea of like
modular systems things that don't have
to be the same every time you wear it
also i switch out exacto knives pretty
much every
every other shoe just to keep the make
sure the blade is
sharp and you're getting a nice clean
edge on it
i think the x-acto knife is just such a
versatile tool
you can lift up stitches individually
and kind of unveil what's underneath it
or just go really hard and just start
ripping it off
that has to be the best feeling can you
tell that how much i love the exacto
knife because i do
all right the puzzle begins
this part is very like composition
based where you just have to move things
around until you start to
like the color and the position of
things
i'm trying to focus on the kind of the
curvature of the collar here
so i have this nice curved part of the
toe box that i can
include and then it has more of a
straight edge where it is along the shoe
so it will be nice and flush
along the zipper opening and then
just some fluidity within the arms here
i don't know if i've
quite gotten there yet because that
piece is a little too jagged
but something maybe that's more curved
off will be able to fit there
so there's some like small sections that
i don't
have a piece for yet but i think
once i continue to get the larger shapes
i can start to fill in the smaller
pieces
so i need to take apart a couple more
[Music]
shoes
[Music]
i'm looking at this one because i know
it's going to be so hard to take apart
but
i like the color and i don't have that
much green i only really have this like
lime hit here and a little bit of the
turquoise but
that that green is kind of punchy i mean
it's subtle but i think it needs it to
balance it out
i'm just wondering how i want to tackle
this because
it's gonna be tough but
we're here we're here to have some
challenges today so
getting a true workout today
[Music]
that's how you know it's hard to get
there you have to use two hands on the
scissor
[Music]
no turning back now
[Music]
i don't always love to credit it but
social media
gave me the platform to be able to to
share these things and ultimately like
make this possible the reception in the
beginning was
not it wasn't bad it was just like
what is she doing like is she okay like
why is she posting these things and i
still get that i still get people just
writing on it and just being like
well why and to me i'm just kind of like
well why not
i mean someone has to put tennis balls
on their foot and call it a shoe like
someone has to be the one to do it and
at least start a conversation
okay i think i can see some really nice
shapes that i like i
actually really like that i was able to
include a few
full pieces of an upper so you know what
it is
and then as well as the scraps i was
able to get some loops in
i was pretty happy that i was able to
get this asics
shiny running shoe in there i'm still
not sure if i'll end up keeping the
zipper or not
it really depends on how stiff this ends
up being
but it's uh it's going to be trial and
error for the next couple of steps
next up we're going to do the pinning
the pinning process is very important to
my design and anything that i make
whether it's shoes or
chairs or i don't know any large scale
thing too
it's just it's a way to be able to
visualize and see a final result without
committing
it also helps getting a feel for the
material
itself and what's going to be harder to
sew and
they're meant for like just holding
delicate pieces of fabric together but i
pin them into shoes i pin them into
my body oh yeah i've definitely
stabbed myself multiple times like
because sometimes i'm just reckless i
honestly i feel like i don't even
recognize it sometimes i'll be like
making a piece and i don't even realize
it but i'll have like
a cut and i'm like oh [ __ ] i need to put
a band-aid on like
before i bleed on everything
[Music]
i i just feel like it can't be that
interesting to watch pinning for me it's
like therapeutic but i usually do this
while i'm watching like
netflix or something or listening to
crime
podcasts which is usually the case
[Music]
it actually was better than i thought it
was going to be
i was kind of like not super sure
just in terms of overall composition
seeing it on
kind of helped me understand like
balance and i'd say for the most part
pretty well balanced i
definitely needed those little two pops
that i added in
and then yeah there's a couple of holes
that i need to
find a little patch for and then
i feel pretty good about it i'm just
trying to see maybe if there's
any of these little open spaces
um if i have anything already that's cut
like little pieces of tongs or
anything that might be able to snug
right into that space
that's kind of nice with the zip detail
something like that might be kind of
nice to add in
so i'm just trimming off some pieces to
clean it up a little bit
in areas where there's a little bit like
overlap off the sides
and just to start getting to the next
stages of sewing
i'm actually going to take a picture of
it in case something
shifts or falls off i'll remember where
it was
but i mean this part is very
fluid and if it starts moving in a way
that it looks
more correct or kind of goes more with
the natural shape
i'm always open to start switching up
the placement of things as you stitch it
on
i think it's time to start sewing
hand sewing takes a long time but it's
very rewarding
using machine is faster but
for some reason i feel like i lose the
craftsmanship something about the hand
sewing process for me i feel like i have
a lot more control over
especially with using such thick
materials i just want to make sure it's
precise
i want to feel like i i don't know i'm
i'm
with the material i'm one with the
material when i'm hand sewing
so i started to use fishing line for
these types of projects because
it's really durable because it's meant
to be pulled and
messed around with and it's clear
so it also kind of melts into the shoe
fabric that's all
the best way i could describe it because
when you're going through those mesh
holes and stuff it becomes so
fine that like you could barely even see
it
[Music]
there's a very blurry line i've have
found personally between art and fashion
and people ask me that question a lot
they're like well what do you consider
it and i'm like
it really depends on the piece it
depends on the day but i
personally just appreciate garments that
do their job and
just really function well
[Music]
i think as adults we end up putting
ourselves
in a box and we don't always allow
ourselves to
explore any kind of weird or crazy ideas
that we might have and i was like that
at first i was like why am i
thinking about packaging materials as a
jacket like that doesn't seem like a
very natural thing
and i was like you know what why don't i
just try to make it and see what happens
and if you just allow yourself to
explore those weird ideas
something really awesome might come out
of it
i think that was the last stitch i think
we finally did it
i'd say one of the harder parts was
some of these leather and suede pieces
just naturally the material
is a little less forgiving when you're
trying to
stick the needle through but for the
most part i think those open meshes
have helped me a lot and i went through
less needles than i normally do on shoes
um but my hands are my hands are super
tired from
sewing and i i feel like i got a good
hand workout doing this
i'm gonna just trim off some excess
threads and
anything that's left over but these are
just some finishing touches that i like
to do
i think i got all the pins out but i'm
gonna do my magnet trick
just to be sure i use magnets just to
kind of feel around and if it starts to
pick up anything that means that i maybe
had left a pin
inside of it and so i move it around and
it doesn't suck it out but you can feel
if
there's something left behind which
i just felt actually so i'm glad that i
use this
because you don't want to put this on
and then get poked later on
so i ended up keeping the collar i think
it's going to look good with a black
shirt i'm just going to keep it for now
i can always take it off later
and i think that's the beauty of doing
custom
designs because you know it doesn't this
doesn't have to be the final form i
could still adjust it later and add
things or take things off as i need to
i pretty much take everything apart
after i make it it's i get the idea out
there
i look at it i capture it in that moment
and then i take it apart and think about
it in a different way and
i've gone through many many generations
of
products and things that have been
clothing to furniture back to clothing
and i really will work with an item
until it's
just a piece of scrap that's that big
and then maybe it will finally have
its final form but i still think i'm too
new in the process to have
final forms because if i continue to do
this forever
i can always continue to use these
pieces until hopefully
something will be good enough to stick
i'm excited about the finished piece
it's very intense and i like that
it is i think this is more of an art
piece it is fashionable it's wearable
it has a pocket that functions but to me
it's it's kind of bold it's a little bit
crazy to wear that
but it's the concept and the idea of
just using materials in a
non-traditional sense and
i think that truly captures it it's
definitely
heavy and warm and
tactile it's like a bullet proof shoe
vest
it is daunting to think about the amount
of waste the amount of things that we
owed in the consumer habits
that have been kind of instilled in us
but that doesn't mean that we can't
take a step back and choose better
options or at least
try to use what we already have instead
of buying something that's new there's
simple solutions to getting involved in
sustainability it's really just thinking
about what you have
do i really need this new thing and if i
do
like can i can i keep it for a really
long time and
be able to prolong the life of it and i
say this in a way where it's like you
don't have to be a designer you don't
have to take it to the extreme that i'm
doing it
even if you're not super into designing
or wanting to create stuff there is ways
that you can maximize
the things that you have what's going to
happen
i mean honestly
i'll probably end up taking it apart and
making it into something else but
i don't know maybe it'll end up back as
a vest someday